[Musique]
c'est en somme un patois merde c'est pas
grave on fera demain non mais je vais me
distributeurs je n'ai pas de ce compte
ok je m'adore bah ouais chez moi j'avais
pas bougé
excusez moi je suis désolé vraiment
comme tout le monde maintenant à lisier
j'ai tout vu
ou la commande a trop
savez quoi je vais vous aider c'est un
put
voilà
brossard
bonne soirée
ah [ __ ] attendait monsieur s'il vous
plaît attendez puisque la machine marche
qui plus est ce qu'on peut être
s'arranger pour les capable
genre
[Musique]
un bon
derrière non non non en fait je venais
chercher 2
la farine de sarrasin mais vous n'avez
pas du coup cette boîte de capotes
comment vous avez fait je sais tout sur
mon établissement
attendez c'est peut-être pas la peine de
m'insulter non à l'eau le policier je
suis en train de me faire breaker à
ramallah [ __ ] ça se voit dans l'étude
les déterminer de quoi ça va beaucoup
d'effets times adrian accor sa fierté je
peux plus respirer avait l'air étonné
mais tu ne seras pas ce soir
j'arrête papapapa tadoussac
tu m'avais parlé mais toi tu poses
excusez-moi ses vergers en fait c'est
juste que j'ai une petite galère vas-y
tu veux quoi tu vois que très non non
non enfin si si si en fait tu vis avec
ma copine est en fait on n'avait pas de
protection et du coup je me bats je me
demandais si vous auriez pas une petite
un petit peu de cas des pannes ou quoi
peut qu'apprécier ainsi fait lui une fin
si à l'ouest
[Rires]
paris n'est pas ici le gaspacho tu fais
là pourquoi tu as frappé là je crois je
trouvais bon quoi je savais pas comment
lui dire que la relève tarde à mes
questions mais de quoi tu m'as dit je
suis motivé mais ferme ta gueule je vois
pas de cm2
[Musique]
sans jugement
monsieur souley attentes à tanger pour
les quatre formations obligatoires
une pièce aussi mais j'en ai ren besoin
de ça bonsoir excusez moi je suis désolé
dorje vous aurez pas un préservatif à
dépanner on fait du vin commune qui
m'attend ça fait deux heures que je suis
parti j'ai plus de batterie j'ai même
pas pu les envois de messages et de est
en panique là il faut vraiment que je
fasse l'amour je me si vous avez ça vous
me sauvé la vie parce que là elles
donneront pour un combat de cire
calme-toi je crois nervuré quoi ça c'est
capot nervuré avec sa tacopina va
s'envoler au paradis voilà merci avec
plaisir
merci beaucoup est il va à fond 1-1
merci champions réseau croissant semaine
prochaine
et enfin pour une pièce est si bien
euros bien que je t'embrasse me veut
alors je suis ton ami
ouais on a un peu quoi c'est pas grave
tu veux ça tombe sont à garder ça aubin
non non non non non ça me gêne quoi sert
le nom martha coakley ça fait plaisir à
moi ces gens qui inquiète à tous et
merci
[Musique]
je
pas tant thébaux paraît
gabriel j'ai trouvé une capote on va
voir bizet et en plus elle est
merveilleuse
bon ben ben maman maman ben
l'avantagé avec les soirées poker c'est
que je reviens avec les croise je
reviens de croatie
[Musique]
d'accord vous compris plein vous avez
bien fait d'hésiter benjamin mercurey
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé notre
premier sketch et gold moustache on
espère qu'il vous a plu si vous voulez
vous abonner à notre chaîne c'est juste
à gauche laamouri quentin et puis si
vous cliquez sur la capote
vous allez regardez le making of et
merci beaucoup d ménard bure et ça me
fait vachement plaisir sinon il ya plein
d'autres sketch jeu sympa à voir sur la
chaîne golden moustache
à bientôt vous fait des bisous salut
ciao les mecs guise yassa